the couple in third place is normani and
now I mean you know you're never really
guaranteed it was quite a shocker for me
as well but I've gained so much from
this experience I'm so happy and I can't
even begin to express you know the
gratitude that I carry and the blessing
especially because I have a lifelong
friend now and I've learned so much
problem being able to see my family and
my girls in the audience super problem
you cheer me on like that means so much
more Rashad Jennings takes the the
Mirrorball your reaction to that crowd
that's like my big brother yeah yeah and
he's worked his butt off I think that
you know any one of us would have been
deserving the good thing is out of all
this now you're clear to go on a date
with boner because this the finals are
over oh shoot I did say that huh nor
money will you go on a date with me nor
money it would be an honor to go on a
date with you now yes I will go out with
you don't happen to let you know well
you're busy you're going back on tour I
have a few radio shows I do and then new
music coming out very soon yeah I could
see Val like on the road with you as a
roadie heck yeah
my number one fan
you